[Music]  well Elizabeth Alexandra Mary is not the  only queen in England right now because  Queen B is there too  we're talking about Beyonce of course  she is there for the on the run to tour  but even a stage the performer is still  a parent first celebrating the twins  first trip around the Sun with a special  shout out on stage in Manchester the  message was delivered by Beyonce during  their young forever duet  fiancee then saying a cover of Ed  Sheeran's ballad perfect as candid  behind the scenes images of the Carters  were projected for fans at one point B  and J embraced in front of a declaration  that reads quote this is real love and  check out Queen B's arrival leading up  to the concert Beyonce and her mom Tina  or chopper down in two helicopters the  family's next tour stop is tomorrow  night in London  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]